so
[Music]
this individual man then which absolute
being has revealed itself to be
accomplishes in himself as an individual
the movement of sensuous being
he is the immediately present god
consequently his being passes over into
having been
consciousness wit for which god is thus
sensuously present ceases to see and to
hear him it has seen and heard him and
it is because it is only it only has
seen and heard him that it first becomes
itself spiritual consciousness
or in other words
just as formerly he rose up for
consciousness as a sensuous existence
now he has arisen in the spirit
for a consciousness that sensuously sees
and hears him is itself a merely
immediate consciousness which has not
overcome the disparity of objectivity
has not taken it back into pure thought
it knows this objective individual but
not itself as spirit
in the vanishing of the immediate
existence known to be absolute being the
immediacy receives its negative moment
spirit remains the immediate self of
actuality but has the universal
self-consciousness of the religious
community a self-consciousness which
reposes in its own substance just as in
it this substance is a universal subject
not the individual by himself but
together
with the consciousness of the community
and what he is for this community is the
complete whole of the individual
as spirit
paragraph 763 is now going to bring
together some of the elements that were
being put on the table in the earlier
paragraph 762 and also before that we
see talk about the community which we
can understand as miller does put in the
brackets to be the religious community
we have the worshiper the believer and
then we have the eins on the mensch the
individual human in this case you know
translating the individual human as this
individual man makes sense because we're
talking here about jesus christ for
christianity which hegel takes to be the
the ultimate religion right
and so we have three
main
we could call them
[Music]
not elements but rather
manifestations of spirit and spirit is
in
all of these but it's it's not there yet
in its notion as we're gonna see as we
saw in the previous paragraph you know
making this uh analogy to
the consciousness section where we have
you know the immediate uh self the
immediate consciousness uh that's that's
sensuous that's oriented towards the
things that present themselves
uncertainty right then we have getting a
bit more metaphysical getting a bit more
epistemological getting more
sophisticated the thing and its
properties we go back and forth and then
we get this massive brain killer section
of course in the understanding well
we're going to have something like that
going on here
and so this is really the first part of
the progress towards that
so he tells us this individual man this
einstein mensch
which absolute being has revealed itself
to be
accomplishes fulfills is another way
full end it right in himself as an
individual the movement of sensuous
being so there's something happening on
this side of the you know the christ
figure
the jesus guy who's there and then
there's also something happening
correlatively on the part of
consciousness the consciousness of the
believer
so he goes on and he says
he is the immediately and we
lots of immediacy here right unmet
he is the unmediated
present gigan vartiga right
so
present both in the sense of like being
present to people
being like in their face you could say
being available
and also present you could say
temporally and this is where we get into
some interesting
you know implications for
temporality and time that are going to
be spelled out a little bit more in the
next paragraph and those
following
so immediately present god
and then
hegel says and this is a transition
where we might be like
wait a second consequently because he's
present he has to pass over into this
other thing well you know again think of
sen certainty what happened when we were
trying to understand the here and the
now
the here remains
here in this spot but the now sure as
hell doesn't because by the time that
you've said now you're already past that
present moment and the now has become
past something like that is happening
here with this figure being zein
the design of of jesus turns into a
having been geway's enzyme and you know
this makes perfect sense if you think
about it
and we're going to talk about this
gevaze enzyme in two different ways so
he says
consequent consciousness which for god
is thus sensuously present ceases
to see and to hear him
why
well jesus leaves the room
right now you're not seeing him now
you're dependent on what you actually
remember or think of a you know prime
example in matthew right jesus preaches
the sermon on the mount this absolutely
central piece of christian doctrine or
at least it ought to be for anybody who
calls themself a christian by the way
when people like start talking about the
book of revelations or leviticus and
they say i'm a christian i stand with
jesus i always say how you doing with
the sermon on the mount because that is
pretty much the most definitive teaching
that he provided if you're not doing
that you're not a christian you're
actually antichrist you know so there
there's some interesting things there
that we could plumb but think about this
so you're at the sermon on the mount
you're one of these people who's
listening to this guy in the rowboat
hopefully he's got a loud voice or maybe
people in the crowd are repeating what
he's saying to you and you're like you
know hearing these these interesting
things that are being said you're like
wow that's some awesome teaching i'm
glad i got to see god face to face and
hear what he has to say this is awesome
and then jesus retires with his apostles
he's going to go have you know a meal
with them and you're going back to your
tent and you're like
wow that was such an awesome experience
what exactly did he say i hope somebody
wrote this down or helped somebody will
write this down somewhere i'm trying to
remember i think i've got a lot anyway
do you remember what exactly what he
said you're piecing something together
that is now past right
and that's an understanding thing that's
not even the seeing and hearing
so it says
uh it is seen and heard him and it is
because it has it only has seen and hurt
him that it first becomes itself
spiritual consciousness and that's on
the side of the
believer on the side of of the figure
in other words just as he he rose up
formerly for consciousness as a centrist
existence now he has arisen
in the spirit of gesta right it's both
words both terms
are the same they're a rising arising
it's a different form of arising
coming up
standing up literally you know standing
oneself up
so what does this actually
mean for us so he says a consciousness
that sensually sensuously zinalika right
sees and hears him is a merely immediate
consciousness
which has not overcome the
disparity of objectivity has not taken
it back into pure thought that's where
we're trying to go with this pure
thought
the concept not just representation not
just
sensuous uh
perception or something like that
something that really takes root within
a human being but also
within them
as part of a community and within the
community as part of them and
christ in all of them
that's part of what is going on here so
a consciousness that
only sensuously sees and hears is merely
immediate
and it hasn't gone to pure thought it
knows this objective individual but not
itself as spirit so this is you could
say foreshadowing what's going to be
happening
what's wrong
with knowing god as spirit as geist
but not knowing oneself as spirit
well for
for a lot of ways of looking at religion
this would actually be ideal you know
think about the unhappy consciousness
which we
went through you know in the
self-consciousness section which has
been referenced quite a bit in in this
particular part of the religion
portion of the work
for that
there was a torn-ness right on the one
hand the eternal god is way off there
the beyond the yane zeits right and
we miserable worms are over here but
we're lucky in that we get to be related
to that
we don't yet realize
that that gap between us is a product of
our own creation a
a reflection of our own
lack of complete spiritual gestiga
development
what do we do
well for hegel and this is where you
know some religious people are going to
jump ship you can say
the goal is for us to realize that we
are spirit too not just christ
not just god the father or god the
trinity or pick whatever you want
we
we worshipers are also that
right and so this is part of the
reconciliation
or the overcoming of alienation
and separateness that is going to come
about and that has to happen through
something else for hegel this is not
something that the individual does all
by himself in a heroic way going off you
know even the monks in the desert
didn't do it on their own
even the hermits
going off by themselves
exist within a community of saints
right they're not saying ah i'm so cool
i can be god on my own you know just me
and jesus all alone
um
you know the thing about walking on the
seashore that christians have you know
when i was at one time i saw myself you
know
these these paths walking along and
there's two sets of footprints and then
there's only one set of footprints what
did you do jesus you you left me behind
you abandoned me and then jesus says no
no i carried you at that time
none of that for here for hegel
it's within the matrix of the community
this is absolutely important for hegel
so
he goes on and he says
it doesn't know itself a spirit
how can it come to know itself as spirit
in the vanishing
of the immediate existence
known to be absolute being right veisin
the immediacy the immediacy receives its
negative moment a very typical hegelian
thing the negative comes in here and
plays a role there's more than what's
going on in immediacy the opposite of
course of immediacy is mediation lots of
mediation going on here where can the
mediation happen the most in the
community
right
the community which provides a locus of
support
this should make us think back to the
earlier sections right this long
development that took place in the
earlier sections of religion the
discussion of the cult wasn't that so
important that was community wasn't it
and this is community but in a different
way as well
so he goes on and he says
spirit
remains the immediate self of actuality
so veer clique right
but as what something that we saw come
up before
the
universal
algamina right
self-consciousness
of the religious community the
gemini religious is bracketed there but
what community are we talking about
this is the religious community
which reposes in its own substance okay
what does that actually mean well it's
its substance is the people who are part
of the community one of the things to
remember about this so we we talked
about this
being going to having been right a
movement of the presence into the past
what allows that to take place
determinately for human beings um
community
right it's not as if we're just these
totally isolated human beings that like
sprung up on our own like mushrooms
without any cultivation didn't require
any shaping any building didn't require
any sort of you know connecting up with
people i mean the mere fact that you and
i are talking about this book the
phenomenology of spirit that is over 200
years old and is talking about something
that we can actually still make sense
out of means that there is community on
community on community it doesn't mean
that everything is a perfect seamless
whole or that you know we can be
schematic about community and traditions
or stuff like that but it sure as hell
does play an important role you know the
our shared humanity
are shared mentally
right this individual man is revealing
something to humanity about humanity
and not just to the individual worshiper
or even just the community that's there
at that point in time
hanging out with him and you know
turning into a church but throughout
history
and hegel himself is viewing himself as
part of that community he's a rather
unorthodox member of that community
maybe we are too
but this is this is what is going on
here so there's a universality that
community
when it is temporal when it's not just
understood as well you know people have
their background assumptions that come
from their community and this is what
gives them a hermeneutic structure to
understand these no no it's it's the
day-to-day
going to services talking about these
things participating in rituals thinking
about these things wondering if it isn't
all [ __ ]
that is part of this i mean think about
this in the very early community we had
doubting thomas thomas the apostle who
you know when christ shows up talk about
you know alfgestand or isn't in the
spirit this guy shows up and he's like
hey
i'm back and he's like i'm not gonna
believe that you're back until i stick
my fingers into your side where the
wound is and and jesus is like come at
me bro and he's like go ahead you know
and and thomas does that he says okay
now i believe you know
doubt is not something that destroys the
community by itself it may even be an
integral part of it you know and you
think about saying augustine and all of
his
you know what what is this what was
going on here all of this making sense
out of things and that's what happens in
the universal self-consciousness
of the community here not not quite so
developed but look at what hegel does
say
this is a self-consciousness which
proposes in its own
substance just as in it this substance
is a universal subject we saw this
before right substance subject spirit
self these these four things keep coming
up over and over again
not the individual by himself
but together
with the consciousness
of the community
and what he is for this community is the
complete whole of the individual as
spirit
let's ask ourselves which individual is
hegel talking about here is he talking
about the individual human
god incarnate immediately present god
is he talking about the conscious
individual who is the worshiper
well trick question because it's both
both of them are playing a central role
in the community so
the individual by himself
is not you could say truly what he is
except insofar as mediated by the
community which is a community of people
trying to figure out what the hell just
happened here and who is this jesus guy
and what should i be doing and how
should i be relating myself to him and
to the community of which i'm a
part and hegel talks about the community
itself as
having a consciousness a
self-consciousness
it's not just an aggregate
of all of the individuals
so this remains to be developed further
but this is an important
you know continuation of the turning
point
remoteness in time and space is however
only the imperfect form in which the
immediate mode of existence is given a
mediated or universal character it is
merely dipped superficially in the
element of thought it is preserved in it
as a sensuous mode and not made one with
the nature of thought itself
it is merely raised into the realm of
picture thinking for this is the
synthetic combination of sensuous
immediacy
and its universality or thought
here in paragraph 764 hegel is both
giving us a caution
but also showing us how the community is
indeed making progress towards what
we're ultimately wanting
out of christianity out of religion in
general out of spirit
and getting us ready to move into the
final section of the work now this is a
short paragraph so
there actually isn't that much to be
said about it i think it's fairly
straightforward to explain
and i think one of the really
interesting things here is
i mean first of all i do like how
miller
translated this i sometimes get on his
case about
being a little bit too periphrastic and
adding things or subtracting things or
changing terminology this is one where i
think it's actually quite good you know
remoteness in space and time
right if we wanted to be much more
literal we would say like spatial
remoteness time remoteness
but this is a nice phrase so fair
gangnam height right uh the the
case the condition
of having you know moved into this past
that we've just mentioned in the
previous paragraph which is in some
parts uh preserved through the community
not just the individual in their memory
but through the community and if you
consider christianity and the fact that
it survived past the death of its
founder
and then resurrection and ascension and
then you know uh the first generation of
people who actually knew the guy and
then you know continued on past that a
community
is what allows that to happen right so
for going in height doesn't become
ferguson heights you know just uh
forgetting about everything and then you
know uh it should be and fernan right um
that is you know um
a distancing
in
space
and you know you think about the
need that these christians you know
have to go to the holy land and see
where jesus maybe was born and maybe
this happened here and you know all
those sorts of things and people do this
with all sorts of other historical
matters too they go on pilgrimages and
it can be for more secular things uh you
know
americans go to the getty field
battlefield because they can't really
imagine things in their head and they
need to like be there on the hallowed
ground
um well you know most of us aren't that
way you know most of us are
at a distance
so and we're at a distance spatially and
also culturally so there's this
remoteness in space and time
and he says that this is the imperfect
form so this is what the community is
providing but it's an unfulfilled you
know unfolma not having reached its
final destination you could say in
perfect form in which the immediate mode
the vise of existence is given a
mediated or universal character so
it's a remoteness and space and time is
an imperfect form for
the mediation for the universalizing
that the community makes possible
holding all these
things together
here hegel has kind of a funny
play on on words right it's
it undergoes this dipping get out right
it's being baptized right it's being
baptized this immediate mode of
existence dipped superficially in
in what the elements he says
of thought so it's not as if it's just
purely sensuous existence because if it
was
nobody would remember that jesus guy now
nobody would remember that jesus guy
a hundred years after
he appeared if it was only sensuous
existence there has to be some element
of thought but it can be more or less
superficial and you know you think about
the ways in which contemporary
christians picture jesus um you know and
this picture word is actually quite
uh apropos here sometimes it's just in
this very sensuous way sometimes it is
in terms of what hegel is calling
forshaw picture thinking uh you know
sort of an imaginary representation
that's how you can get some big brawny
jesus who's you know got an american
flag in guns or pick whatever other
crazy jesus you want that's not remotely
like the
original or what the
community in fact could have made of him
when it was sticking to
its uh its guns when it wasn't coming
unmoored into a collective
imagination that is less about religion
and more about something else
so
preserved as a sensuous mode
and not made one with the nature of
thought itself so we have a distinction
here between the element of thought
and the nature of thought and the nature
of thought is not being attained yet
because what is the nature of thought
concept the grief the gyphen right the
the notion of the notion that we saw
invoked earlier just a few paragraphs
before that we haven't gotten there yet
but we can see it on the horizon
but we're not there so he says it's
merely raised this sensuous mode this
visor right imagining jesus hanging out
with you and you know
you're doing whatever
walking along the seashore eating fish
together you know learning from the
master
it can be raised into picture thinking
that's an achievement that's better than
just merely sensuous
existence so it's raised into the realm
of picture thinking right and then hegel
tells us something a little bit about
picture thinking here which is kind of
nice to know it is a synthetic
combination a fair binding a bringing
together right it's not just a
bindung it is a fair binding a a intense
combination
of sensuous immediacy and the universal
universality or thought picture thinking
representation foreshadowing always
contains something
universal about it it's more than just
hey i'm seeing this it's a we're seeing
this and it looks like this and we can
move from seeing to describing
or you know we can say well what's
really essential in this that's also
involved in picture thinking but picture
thinking just doesn't go far enough it
remains tied to
this four stellang and we're going to
see why that's a problem in the
following paragraphs particularly why
it's a problem for
religion and for christianity
you